it merely points out that there's an
illusory experience it says there's
separation which then seeks wholeness
which is where wholeness hides
and that just it just clarifies that
that's what's going on
wholeness hides in the illusory
separation
yeah wholeness is separation
the appearance of separation there isn't
anything else
that's why seeking it is hopeless
wholeness is the appearance of
separation there is only wholeness
yeah that's pretty interesting
it's mind-blowing
there's nothing to do with it yeah
maybe that's where the misunderstanding
that there's no that
one shouldn't do anything comes from
because the message itself
has no qual no no usable quality to it
it has no intention in it but it's
ineffable there's no way to point to the
unconditional celebration because there
is only that
because there is only that because
everywhere you point is the
unconditional celebration the pointing
as well
the pointing is as well yeah
wow so yeah so the unconditional
celebration is built synonymous with the
100 million people that died
in the 20th century and
it's also synonymous with pizza
[Laughter]
what this is crazy
yeah oh my gosh got it is so crazy
cool there is only the infinite and yet
there is a zygote that apparently
becomes an adult
yeah which is this the infinite
appearing as the story of a zogo
becoming an adult which is this
okay okay cool
cool
[Laughter]
oh wow